a Ryan Gosling look-alike from Arizona  went viral by asking Emma Stone to prom  with an epic video recreating the  opening of lala land appeared on Good  Morning America Friday and revealed the  oscar-winning actress responded to his  promposal Emma said Jacob in all caps  thanks for making the greatest proposal  I've ever received I can't tell you what  an honor that was and how much I smiled  through that entire beautifully  orchestrated video I'm in London working  but I hope you have the best time at  prom and I'm grateful you thought of me  thank you in all caps and she added PS I  do see Gosling around the eyes you still  go to the prom right  oh of course yeah I'm gonna have a great  time still with all my friends  you  [Music]